have a good time keep your table buck
down to a minimum he stands up to each
other you guys ready for your next comic
this guy's absolutely hilarious you
don't do this all the length of New York
City ladies Nova star pop it right now
put together some gangsters good to be
here my home mates it's funny cuz I look
like this a hard time coming over here
I'd take the normal lane I couldn't take
the carpool lane
what's up says I feel like carpool lanes
like Society saying hey you know how
you're lonely you know what to do that
the longer take the long way don't think
about it watch people with your friends
whizzing by you
[Music]
let's listen help I was walking up an
escalator and there's some dude on the
left hand side and I said excuse me cuz
I was walking up and he moved over but
then he was like dude why do people walk
up escalators that doesn't make any
sense because but then didn't hear how
he ended that sentence cuz I was
covering so much [ __ ] distance giving
the desk
we have to make friends at your passing
out people I sell me and your book smart
but I'm street smart oh you're smart no
way that's not measurable or comparable
a convenient for you
maybe you're not smart maybe you're dumb
and you're insecure about it and that's
why I committed aggravated assault
let's go crying stop touching me it
hurts I'm glad that douchebags don't
give birth I think douchebags in
Terrebonne like women give birth
because if men gave birth we'd be like
bro I believe me so much protein and
creatine during pregnancy the baby's
like 27 pounds or any girl should get a
six-pack in the ultrasound it's all
about those games in the first trimester
I was talking to this girl she was like
did you know that my vagina is a 3d
printer because it can make a baby I was
like that's not even accurate your womb
is a 3d printer your vagina is the tray
it's not even a very good 3d printer
latent prints one thing with lots of
errors takes nine months to print and
the whole time is printing as
complainings did not see any printer
trays at night
something - a friend of mine girls like
dude we're so lucky we're not gay
can you imagine if most of the gender
that we were attracted to wasn't
attracted to his back I was like whoa
can't even imagine we were so different
than us
they must cry constantly just a case I
don't understand homophobia I don't
understand the slogans for homophobia
they'll say it's Adam and Eve not Adam
and Steve but Adam and Eve aren't even a
good couple by any standard first off
they gave birth are they they disobeyed
God and they ain't no fruit which is
kind of gay and also they new birth the
Cain and Abel and Cain murdered Abel so
why are we taking parenting advice from
people raised a murderer
do-don't made three other people on
earth at this psychopathic I can't
handle this man one of these [ __ ] is
together just move you got the whole er
you don't have to kill a quarter of the
world's population
your startup get your [ __ ] together
I'm not gay I love the women I think
they got the best genitals in the human
race definitely in the top three I heart
dating as an Asian man everyone thinks
Asian women are sexy no one things Asian
men are sexy which doesn't even make any
sense I mean how do you think Asian
women are created
I'm in a sexy process the pain of sex
with me our children will be very
beautiful
half of them
[Music]
doesn't have to be great engineers in
unsupported strategies optimization
I love being Asian because whenever
someone is racist to me I'm just like oh
you made it respectful people who hate
to themselves good luck finding an
affordable cover
[Applause]
[Music]